>>> A NEW LOOK SENATOR EDWARD
KENNEDY'S LIFE, HIS DIARY
DETAILS WHAT HE TOOK FROM SAMUEL
ALITO TO RESPECT THE PRECEDENT
OF THE ROE V. WADE RULING.
IT DETAILS CONVERSATIONS THAT HE
HAD WITH ALITO BACK IN 2005.
SENATOR KENNEDY RECORDS ALITO AS
VOWING TO, QUOTE, ADHERE TO
PRECEDENT.
SAYING I BELIEVE IN A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY AND CALLING THE MATTER,
QUOTE, SETTLED.
FAST FORWARD 16 YEARS.
IT WAS JUSTICE ALITO WHO WROTE
THE DECISION ERASING ROE V. WADE
THIS SUMMER AND ENDING ITS
GUARANTEE TO ABORTION RIGHTS,
FEDERAL GUARANTEE.
THE REVELATION COMES FROM THIS
NEW BOOK, INCLUDING
NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN EXCERPTS FROM
THE SENATOR'S OWN DIARY.
THE AUTHOR JOINS US NOW.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET'S CONTINUE FIRST ON THIS
THEME.
WE NOW LIVE IN THE DOBBS
AMERICA, NOT THE ROE V. WADE
AMERICA.
ABORTION IS STATE BY STATE.
SENATOR KENNEDY SUCH A PLAYER IN
THE DAY.
YOU WROTE A PIECE IN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" YESTERDAY ABOUT
KENNEDY ASKING HIM, BECAUSE
ALITO HAD WRITTEN A MEMO WHERE
HE SAID I OPPOSE ROE.
JUDGE ALITO ASSURED MR. KENNEDY
HE SHOULD NOT PUT TOO MUCH STOCK
IN THE MEMO.
HE HAD BEEN SEEKING A PROMOTION
AND WROTE WHAT HE THOUGHT HIS
BOSSES WANTED TO HEAR.
I WAS A YOUNGER PERSON, JUDGE
ALITO SAID.
I HAVE MATURED A LOT.
A, THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS BUT
JUST, B, WHAT DID YOU LEARN
GOING THROUGH THIS FASCINATING
DIARY?
>> AS YOU KNOW, TED KENNEDY HAD
BEEN ONE OF THE LEADERS IN THE
BATTLE TO DEFEAT ROBERT BORK
BACK IN THE REAGAN YEARS WHEN
BORK WAS DOMINATED TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
AND THE LESSON THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY CAME AWAY FROM
WAS THAT WE CAN'T HAVE OUR
NOMINEES GOING UP THERE AND
DOING INTELLECTUAL COMBAT WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BECAUSE WE SOUND TO HEARTLESS
AND WE SOUND LIKE WE ARE GOING
TO DO A WHOLE BUNCH OF STUFF
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T
WANT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THEM GO
UP AND IN A SUCCESSION OF RIP
NOMINEES WENT UP AND ALL SAID
THINGS LIKE I WILL RESPECT
PRECEDENT.
I HONOR WHAT'S HAPPENED BEFORE.
THERE'S A JUDICIAL THEORY CALLED
STARE DECISIS WHICH MEANS WE
DON'T GO BACK AND WRECK
50-YEAR-OLD JUDICIAL DECISIONS.
SO WHEN HE WAS IN THIS PRIVATE
CONVERSATION WITH TED KENNEDY,
JUDGE ALITO SAID THINGS LIKE I
RESPECT PRECEDENT.
I BELIEVE I'M GOING TO ADHERE TO
THAT.
I HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
ALL THINGS THAT SORT OF GIVE THE
INCLINATION THAT HE WOULD BE AT
LEAST A NEUTRAL PERSON ON
SOMETHING LIKE ROE V. WADE AND
OF COURSE HE WAS NOT.
HE WROTE THE DECISION THAT
OVERTURNED IT.
>> OF COURSE HE WAS NOT.
IT'S FASCINATING.
SO MANY BOOKS HAVE BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT THE SENATOR THAT IT IS
REMARKABLE THE REPORTER YOU'VE
DONE TO FIND SO MANY NEW
DETAILS, INCLUDING ABOUT ONE OF
THE GREAT TRAGEDIES IN SENATOR
KENNEDY'S LIFE, THE ACCIDENT AT
C
CHAPPAQUIDDICK.
YOU GOT ACTRESS TO ARTHUR
SCHLESSINGER AND ADVISOR TO
PRESIDENT KENNEDY.
IN THIS DIARY JEAN THINKS THAT
TEDDY PANICKED.
HE HOPED THAT HE COULD FIND SOME
WAY TO COVER IT ALL UP.
WHAT ELSE DID YOU LEARN ABOUT
CHAPPAQUIDDICK?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT HE REALLY
WAS PANICKED BUT HE WAS ALSO
POSSIBLY SUFFERING THE EFFECTS
OF A CONCUSSION FROM THE CAR
ACCIDENT.
HE WAS IN THIS SORT OF DREAM
WORLD OF IMAGINE NAL MAGICAL
THINKING WHERE HE HOPED HE WOULD
SEE MARY JO WALKING DOWN THE
ROAD BUT IN THE END HE MADE A
VERY COLD DECISION THAT EVEN HIS
MOTHER, ROSE KENNEDY, FAULTED
HIM FOR, WHICH WAS TO GO TO
EDGARTOWN, GET DRESSED, GO DOWN
TO A HOTEL LOBBY IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE MORNING AND THEN HAVE
BREAKFAST WITH FRIENDS ON THE
BALCONY AND MAKE IT SEEM THAT HE
HAD NOT BEEN THERE.
FINALLY TWO OF HIS AIDES AND
FRIENDS CAME TO HIM AND SAID YOU
CAN'T DO THIS.
YOU HAVE TO GO REPORT THE CRIME.
AND THAT WAS WHAT HE HAD TOLD
JEAN KENNEDY SMITH, HIS SISTER.
SO THE FIRST TIME WE HAVE THIS
TALE CONFIRMED OUT OF THE
SENATOR'S OWN MOUTH.
>> YOU ALSO HAVE IN HERE AND IT
FITS WITH THIS, ABOUT HIS ROLE
IN THE FAMILY HERE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO CAN MESS UP
IN LIFE AND NOT GET CAUGHT.
TED KENNEDY'S FATHER, JOSEPH,
TOLD HIM YOU'RE NOT ONE OF THEM.
>> THE WHOLE BOOK IS ALMOST A
SHAKESPEAREAN TRAGEDY, ABOUT THE
YOUNGEST SON WHO NEVER EXPECTED
TO HAVE TO SHOULDER THE BURDENS
OF THE CROWN.
THROUGH AN INCREDIBLE SERIES OF
EVENTS, THE THREE OLDER BROTHERS
SUFFER VIOLENT DEATHS.
HERE'S TEDDY UNPREPARED, IGNORED
FOR LARGE SECTIONS OF HIS
CHILDHOOD AND NOW HE'S THE ONE
WHO HAS TO CARRY THE BURDEN,
CARRY THE MANTLE FORWARD.
>> FASCINATING WORK ABOUT A
FASCINATING MAN.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY,